what's happening you bad [__]
the joint is here happy thanksgiving
the joint is brought to you by manscape
hold up before you carve that turkey you
better make sure your giblets are ready
to be on full [__] display
and it all starts with the lawnmower 4.0
manscape is in the house uncle joey's
here to tell you manscape is the [__]
best the ceramic blade reduces grooming
accidents is gentle on the nut sack and
it's easy to maneuver and waterproof
you could shave around the pole of life
and now you compare that with manscape's
new body wash with aloe vera sea salt it
leaves you feeling moist refreshed and
with a taste of yourself you taste like
gravy with all the [__] trimmings you
understand me [__] manscape is not
messing around just in time for the
holidays
they got the two-in-one shampoo and
conditioner
the whole package works together from
the top of your head all the way to your
dangling [__] stick of life that's
why they call it the perfect package
get it now for christmas this is what
your uncle needs this is what your
grandfather needs this is what your
[__] aunt needs this is what your
brother needs the whole package works
together that's why they call it the
perfect package and now you can get the
weed whacker nose and head trimmer that
prevents knicks snags and tugs in those
delicate holes but wait there's more you
get the crop preservable deodorant
[__] tremendous and the crop reviver
ball toner oh my god
it leaves your ball sack nice and
[__] smooth so when they put their
tongue on it they're like what do we
have in our mouth cotton [__] no it's my
nut sack made by manscape [__]
and they got two more goodies manscaped
anti-chafing boxes and a [__]
travel bag and the travel bag has a
little zipper inside you can hide your
[__] in there but you didn't hear this
from uncle joey when you go around the
table this year tell everybody you love
what you're thankful for clean and fresh
balls and you're thankful for manscape
and uncle joey for giving you this
[__] deal you get 20 off free
worldwide shipping i don't give a [__]
if you're in bulgaria somalia i don't
give a [__] i'm giving you 20 off and
free [__] shipping that's 20 off from
free shipping at manscape.com
joey clean up your [__] candy cane
because [__] christmas is coming and
manscaped is going to help you out to
get your dick sucked on a daily
basis the joint is also brought to you
by
c b d lion
let me tell you something i had a little
problem sleeping this week you know i
like to switch my stuff around
i went back to the cbd
[__] gummies oh my god i slept like a
baby
whether it's the gummies the tincture
the [__] kinesiology tape listen
cbd lion's main goal is to bring cbd
to you not that cbd you go to the gas
station
real cbd so it's touched by you going to
cbdlion.com
and reading the third party lab results
again this also makes a great christmas
gift a little cbd thing [__] from cbd
lion
holy [__] they'll be calling you by
mid-january saying what's in that
[__] stuff i'm feeling 10 years
younger and energetic that's what cbd
lion does for you so do me a favor go to
cbdlion.com
read
what cbd cbn cby could do for you and
pick one of the great selections of
however you want to induce it whether
you want to smoke it whether you want to
put a patch on your elbow whether you
want to put a patch on your knee or your
whatever you whatever
you have that's wrong with you cbd lion
is there to help you okay so do me a
favor go to cbdline.com
get yourself some gummy bears to start
off with use code joey and get 20 off
delivery right to your [__] house
that's what cbd lion does for you i've
been working with cbd lion now for three
years and they've helped me through two
surgeries and all my other old man [__]
when you're looking for help it's cbd
lying to the rescue again use code joey
and get 20 off delivered to your house
cbd lion the best in the industry and
from the heart of [__] new
jersey the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen the nfl nhl season is
underway and draftkings sportsbook has
an unbelievable offer to celebrate the
greatest sport on ice new customers can
bet just one dollar on any nhl game and
100 and free bets defeat the team scores
a goal
that's only way to warm up your nuts on
the ice with a little extra cash stuffed
in your [__] pockets this week
the cheat the philadelphia flyers
are gonna try to put one over on the
world champion tampa bay lightning this
is where you come in i love draftkings
listen i've tried a couple other sites
but there's nothing like draftkings they
give you information that is invaluable
to have strategies on top they have a
social network and we could communicate
on there you could say joey who do you
[__] like tonight it doesn't matter
if it's a one-time clapper or a death
deflection however they light the lamp
you [__] win if sportsbook isn't
available in your state that's all right
draftkings ain't gonna leave you with
your dick in your hand they got a
tremendous fantasy
daily fantasy sports contest and they're
giving away huge catch prizes all season
long with draftkings daily fantasy
sports book listen to me i'm i don't go
to the draftkings all the time
monday night i didn't want to bet the
giant [__]
tampa bay game you know what i bet i bet
the first score i didn't know if it was
tampa bay or the giants i put 25 dollars
i won 48 bucks and i went to sleep
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot of millions of dollars in
total prize with their first deposit
listen i love draftkings they're safe
secure and i can trust them and they're
reliable and best of all you can
withdraw your cash whenever you want i
love them to debt
they got prop bets that'll [__] make
you more money than the goddamn game and
that's what i like about draftking
sportsbook whether it's nba
uh nfl nhl hockey
ufc soccer draftkings sportsbook has you
covered so do me a favor download the
draftking sportsbook app right now and
use promo code joey throw down a dollar
on any nhl game and win 103 bets and
feed the team scores a goal this week
one puck hits the nets and you're a big
winner when provo code joey at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nhl now
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania colorado west
virginia
legal states only please new customers
only minimum five hour deposit and one
dollar wager required and only one turn
per customer don't be a [__] garbone
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem i don't want to make it
worse i'm not here to [__] you know
call 1-800 gambler but
first if you don't have a problem head
to draftkings and let's win some
[__] christmas getters and some
dick sucking getters do you understand
me
draftkings.com download it and let's win
some dough i love you [__] it's
wednesday before thanksgiving
we got [__] to do
and people to [__] see
thank god i got this candle lit let's do
this [__]
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 24th of november
pre-thanksgiving podcast you bad
[__]
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive we're here we're queer
some [__] going down did you guys see
what the [__] happened in california
with 80 people they got an 80 man gang
and they just busted into the [__]
whatever store
and took everything it was the biggest
smash and grab in the history of smash
and grabs i saw that [__] and i was like
that's some [__] interesting [__]
i'm a [__] criminal type of guy
myself and i never thought about that
enterprise that's not a bad [__] idea
i mean you remember like lex luthor
remember like when you watch shows and
[__] there was always that criminal
enterprise guys yeah
yeah see we're gonna do this like this
is always his name was always lefty or
louie and he you know like when you
watch [__] superman too luke
luke
lex luther was in charge of the crime
and all like when you watch the batman
shows penguin they all had these
criminal enterprises i'm in the mood now
to put together a i never considered
myself a criminal [__] enterprise
even though i was a [__] criminal i
got to tell you
when i was in boulder
in 94 or 95
i was a criminal one-man show
organization i'm not very proud of this
but holy [__] that i go off in that town
i never went back to boulder
because of the [__]
just the way i acted it was not the way
you act in boulder you know those people
in boulder were very nice [__] people
and i unleashed a crime spree in boulder
from [__]
in 1985 i moved to boulder the first
time
and i remember this is the [__] that
i was i remember walking around on a
sunday night
having money in my pocket and having
money in my bank account one of the only
times in my life i had a substantial
[__] bank account and walking on the
boulder mall one night on a sunday night
i was i used to steal just because i was
bored
like who the [__] does that there was
one of those cookie things one of those
cookie things that you go to at the mall
they have like chocolate chip cookie
yeah what do they call sarah
lee or something i don't [__] know
they just sell chocolate chip cookies
chunk macadamia they got some brownies
in there it's like a kids store
they left the window open like this much
and i was walking by
and i ripped the screen off went in
there i stole
if there was 35 dollars in there it was
too much
so when i saw that it was just 35 i
couldn't get into the safe i just stole
some cookies i brought the cookies home
with me like 12 [__] cookies like
that's the [__] that i was you know
what
did i get from breaking into that cookie
place i broke a window
i got 35 dollars i broke the register it
cost them a bunch of money awake and
they come in the next day and they see
what the [__] is going on
i got cookies all over the [__] floor
the window's broken you know what did i
[__] accomplish that's why i never
understood why pete like my wife loves
to leave like if she'll take a doll out
for the toll she'll leave the dollar in
the middle and close the door
guess what
somebody will break your window for that
dollar
how do i know because i did it i would
[__] do it i would break a window for
a dollar because i thought there was
more in there
you follow me when you're a [__] when
you're the mind of a criminal you think
there's more in there
and that's why it's not worth it's like
when you steal i never stole a car
stereo number one i always knew that
when the cars like if you get a car
stereo from stock
and you take it out it's not gonna work
on another car you [__] idiot so i
was never really a stereo [__] guy
like and i had friends who that's what
they did every night they went out and
busted into cars and
stole stereos out of cars that was that
always seemed [__] childish to me but
see as roebuck in ritual park put their
[__] car stereos they had those blou
punks they put about 300 of them by the
door like a christmas sale one year me
and don rego [__] took every single
one of them we'd go there and take five
of the [__] shot put them in the back
and [__] tail off it was it was
[__] crazy one day me and
were in the car we we quit you know like
we were in high school we said [__] we
got to play hooky we have no money
rhaego came from the same house as me
you know his parents gave him like 20
hours for the week and that was it if
you want to do coke you want to do
quality you want to get your dick sucked
you got a steel jack so we would hook up
in the morning see them because there's
no security at the stores early in the
morning
they don't get into like 12. so we would
go like a 10
and [__] you know take off five car
stereos do fake returns and [__] like
that
but one time we took a bunch of [__]
car stereos and he was in the ice box he
had this car that we called the ice box
because they had no heat you know like
when your father and parents first give
you a car they give you their car when
it's beat up when you first get your
first 16 and a half his car was called
the ice box
and it was tougher than [__] nails
this car and i'll never forget that we
loaded the the five stereos in the trunk
of the car
and he went to back up i'll never forget
he was doing maybe 10 miles an hour he
hit this car
he dented the [__] car and the car
was shaking
as we were driving off i'm like damn
look at that [__] car it was doing
the mumbo by himself it was just shaking
and then it just stopped that's how hard
he hit that [__] car so when it comes
to criminal enterprises i've always
thought i'm pretty good at it like i
could always divide you know i did all
that [__] like i did the gas stations in
jersey i've been allowed to say that too
loud because i'm here now and they'll
come get me but they got to prove it
it's it was 19 yeah they're in no danger
they got to find a witness if you worked
in a gas station 85 you're not in good
shape right now trust me i'm telling you
so who gives a [__] they're never going
to find me but i did that
every day in new york and new jersey for
[__] months and then i just left i
just got on a plane on the people's
express and just [__] left to
colorado and they're like staking gas
stations out like they were staking
that's how many gas stations i was just
getting a job in and robbing they didn't
send the memo out to gas stations or
anything the last gas station i did was
a [__] like uh i just saw that did
you see in jersey they they made all the
all the [__] uh gas stations a
different name so like somebody took a
picture the other day and it was bruce
springsteen
gas station like uh that was james
gandolfini anybody from new jersey now
has their own little gas station in
memoriam you know what i'm saying like
if they did good things
yeah like the turnpike ones you know so
there's one called the vinslim body
[__]
whatever up north it's up north it's
like a parking ride
when i saw that gas station i was like
eureka because i was stealing like
[__] you know you go to a gas station
i have like two [__] islands four
islands like i was doing those little
gas stations like mom and pop gas
stations but one day i was taking a ride
out to little ferry or some [__] and i
saw my buddy had a i saw that that i saw
that
center you know the vince lombardi
[__] center listen to me
they got like a hundred islands
in my mind
this was oh my god this was like the
pierre de la resistance i was gonna
[__] i was working at a high volume
[__] place like all the other what
i'm trying to say is all the other
places where mom and pop grandma place
and i was still getting cash
this was a high volume place i was going
to hit this big like this was my last
[__] hit i was going to colorado and
that's it
i'm not i got away with it for two
months i went to this [__] gas
station
they told me to come in at one i went at
one and it was one car after the other
jack
they weren't [__] around i didn't
turn around all i kept doing was five
fill it up 10 15 fill it up and i'm you
know me i'm putting [__] two dollars
and i'm hanging pumps i'm stealing from
all directions i got money in this
pocket money in this pocket money in my
sock money in my nut sack i got money
[__] everywhere and finally like
it started it looked like it was gonna
rain i was gonna milk that [__] gas
pump until ten i think it was a one to
ten gap shift the first hour they made
me pump with somebody else then after
that they let me go on my own and gave
my own bank
holy [__] i looked i swear to god you
know when when you're pumping gas you
get a wad about four inches long
don't get me wrong it's a jew roll you
know there's a lot of singles in there
and whatnot there's a lot of [__]
but it was this [__] big and the guy
kept asking me did you have you dropped
yet i'm like yeah i kept dropping like a
hundred dollars he's like you gotta drop
a thousand of the time [__] you
let me tell you something when that
[__] thunder hit
i i went up to him and i go hey i gotta
go to the bathroom he's like it's all
the way over there you gotta wait to
your [__] [__] you i'm going to the
[__] bathroom that's by the law i
can't go to the bathroom i'm working and
i just went into the [__] thing and i
walked out with the rest of the people
and i got on that [__] bus and i
walked all the way to the back i took
out that wad it was list [__] thick i
wanted my nut sack i had another five
[__] hundred dollar bills in there it
was a score you don't count the money
till you get to new york city it's bad
luck you know what i'm saying you don't
want to give the universe the thought
that you think you got away with it yet
so i just sat in my seat there
and people getting on the bus and it's
starting to fill up and buses are
[__]
lining up lining up lining up and i'm
like when the [__] is this bus gonna
take off
and i look over and i see [__] cop
cars and i see a little indian dude the
dude who hired me talking to a [__]
cop and the cops are coming in from all
over looking and they're busting and
they're going into the [__] service
station and i'm on the bus sitting there
going bus driver we got to speed it up a
little bit we're gonna hit some [__]
traffic the guy's like i gotta wait for
everybody to come on the [__] bus
what are you talking about and finally
[__] one person came on more more and
more i'm looking they're looking around
they started looking around they're like
where could he have disappeared to
and they look back and they're like
maybe he's on the bus
and they started looking at the buses
and i'm like oh [__] i'm dead they're
going to come on the bus
and i just said
god [__] bail me out of this one and
i'll never rob another gas station again
and next thing you know i heard the
engine opening up and they started
getting the cars and going to the buses
but they went
to the first bus first was like four
buses from me i thought they were gonna
shut down all the buses and my bus
drivers said [__] it let's get out of
here we got out of there i remember like
[__] not even looking at the cops and
the little indian dude i just pulled out
of there
next thing you know we're on the
turnpike headed into manhattan i still
had one more [__] obstacle
port authority in new york
sometimes they said cops there one time
they did it to me i got into a little
beef on the fort lee side when i got to
the port authority side there were two
cops there to [__] greet me to
welcome me to new york
but i told them what had happened they
said [__] get the [__] out of here so
i [__] uh that was the end i [__]
landed in port authority
i walked out i'm like god please
i hope there's not a cop here i got to
get to colorado i walked off there
wasn't a cop to be seen
i went straight to a martial arts store
and i bought that bruce lee suit from
game of death with the yellow and the
[__] black stripe and then i took it
home and i didn't fit in it so what a
waste of [__] time that was but i
made out with some money but my point
being that i was i always looked at
myself
as a criminal type of guy i always like
found like a loophole am i proud of this
no guy
no guys but when you're doing coke this
is the [__] you think of you know i was
talking to
rich voss and we were talking about
drugs you know and uh
the effects on drugs and he was telling
me that
when he was getting high 30 years ago
that he was smoking crack with a friend
of his one day in philly
and one of his friends [__] took the
biggest hit a crack
and put the pipe down and then fell out
of the car
like his lungs like he just fell out of
the [__] car he was coughing and he
said that rich he goes this is my best
friend
and at that moment i'm hoping that he
dies so i could take his money and his
drugs in his car and go home
but he wouldn't do that today but that
just goes to show you the mind of an
addict that's how we always think you
are your best friend he dies of a hit
off crack you're not gonna take him to
the doctor [__] him you're gonna take
his crack take his money and his car and
leave him there that's that's your way
your mind goes
so you know
that's just the way life is that's you
know my mind hasn't thought like that in
years but when my mice were when my mind
was racing
that's what it was racing it was racing
all those how to make a buck how to
[__]
rob somebody how to break into a house i
mean i would just come i would go to a
doctor's office let's say i was going to
a doctor's office and on the walk to the
doctor i saw something
all that [__] would go away [__] the
doctor in his office i'm going to rob
something i remember having a lawsuit
and i had to go to a chiropractor for
him to [__] check me out
and see where we were going and the next
thing you know i went there
it was a saturday the boom boom mancini
fight was on this is back in 81 82 83.
everybody was watching the boom boom
mancini fight it was a fight to the
death i went to the bathroom and on the
way to the bathroom at the doctor's
office i saw there was a suitcase in one
of the doctor's office
you know i opened up that [__]
picked the checkbook and the [__]
prescription pad what
what was i gonna do with it i didn't do
anything with it the checkbook i gave it
to a friend and what happened a week
later the cops come to my house he got
arrested with the [__] checkbook and
i got a conspiracy to [__] defraud
somebody or some [__] i think i still
got the war in bergen county they just
got rid of it when i moved back 30 years
[__] later so that was always my luck
you know what i'm saying but
this uh
i think it's a pandemic i don't know
what sparked it but these criminals have
been coming out everywhere i saw the
[__] numbers
water boxer one of the guys i follow on
twitter good guy posted the numbers for
california
a couple days ago
everything except car
theft
rose 77
murders are up 77
aggravated robberies with a weapon are
up 70 percent
robberies are up 70
muggings are up 60 percent card thefts
are up 50
these are all organized guys this is not
they banded together last year this last
summer was when they
[__] hatched their plan and if you
look at vegas if you look at
san francisco if you look at california
if you look at portland
chicago [__] crime is up
big time i mean big time weapons murders
are up big time
i don't know what's happening to the
world right now but
it just doesn't [__] feel right
that's why i'm happy
it's thanksgiving today we were supposed
to have a zoom with steve simone because
nobody yells thanksgiving more than me
and steve simone being together that's
uh
family you know i dig steve a lot he's
down in florida
when the pandemic happened in california
me steve
dean
lee
jimmy shubert
dan i forget what his name is we all got
so tight
that was the one thing about the
pandemic that
i think i've gotten tighter with my
people
because
i have a small circle in new jersey but
i care for them a lot like mike i care a
lot about mike my circle isn't as big as
la anymore
but it's just so weird how you
you join together with your people when
things go danger i remember 9 11 you
know
9 11
happened you know in the morning and i
was home and all of a sudden i got a
call from rogan
who never used to come down at daytime
very rarely unless he was coming down
for a meeting or something
he called me up on 9 11 that morning
he's like how do you feel i'm coming
down i remember that we all went to mike
feyerman's house a bunch of us ricky
cruz
ralphie
[__] all of us just got together that
day
and whatever you had going on you put it
aside and we all were sitting by the tv
i think about those days and i'm like
wow man
we really had a special thing there and
i remember after faveman's house we all
went to ralphie's me jay moore [__]
celine jodie ferdig [__] josh wolfe
that had to be 20 of us ralphie was
poor as [__] at that time we all were
and ralphie me we all chipped in and put
together a [__] gumball
on 9 11 the original day and i'll never
forget i got mad at jay moore because he
criticized ralphie shrimp i mean we
didn't have no money you know what i'm
saying it's not like we could buy
[__] prawns for this uh jambalaya so
we just bought the little katrina shrimp
you know the little ones that came from
katrina
pre-katrina [__] they had eyes and
[__]
and you know jay was saying [__] but
that doesn't matter we we had such a
good time you know and that's the whole
thing like
people never really understood
why i wanted to come back to jersey
people never really understood i'm gonna
tell you now after 15 [__] months
i wanted to be close to family
again you're like joey not for nothing
you got no family i got no blood family
but i got tons of family here
and some of these people that i've just
recently met
they're becoming my family like the way
mike is you know we just this is it this
is it guys
i don't like acquaintances i don't like
small chatter i like you to be involved
with me or not take a [__] hike if
you're not in you know what i'm saying
if i don't know your daughter's name if
you don't know my daughter's name if i
don't know
it's it's like uh you know
but it's so weird i got family i wanted
to get close we were
looking at a
a time in this country right now
we're not in a good place guys we're
[__] around here on the podcast we're
cracking stupid jokes and [__] but
we're doing all right but there's a lot
of [__] people that are struggling
right now a lot of people that are
[__] struggling i mean
you know financially um
mentally is the big one
i mean i'm no [__] genius but you go
on social media
and there's a lot of people [__]
losing it if you guys know this i
haven't been [__] around too much on
social media i wish you a nice good
morning i put up the podcast i put up a
song and i move along i wish you a good
day
it's not good guys i get insulted every
time this has never happened
like this has never [__] happened to
me where you post something positive not
about ain't like you know
you know i don't give a [__] about pete
and [__]
kardashian i mean you know
is life this bad that we all got to live
vicariously
through kim kardashian
i love pete davidson he's a great
[__] kid with the emphasis on kid
he's a kid he's just looking to have fun
all these people online [__] what's
still lure pete davidson he's a kid he's
27 years old he's probably got a nine
inch [__] with a tattoo on it you know
what i'm saying and he's on one of the
best shows on [__] television i don't
like the show but it is one of the best
shows on television you get on a show on
a television i don't care if you're
missing [__] an eye and you got one
thing ahead you're gonna find some bits
to suck your dick because they're gonna
think you're special
so he's good looking he's got a great
[__] job he's a comedian what else do
you need he's gonna [__] [__] all the
time if you're gonna stop every time he
[__] a [__] to analyze the situation
you're gonna lose just cause he's gonna
keep [__] [__] kim is just a
little kim is just a couple months he'll
dump her they'll break up and like the
way he was with the chick from [__]
underground because that's the hardest
chick in the [__] world underworld
that whatever [__]
cape back and sale
is [__] smoking
and it's not even a body in her face
wait till she opens her mouth with that
little australian accent you're like
what the [__] whatever it is australian
english it makes my dick card no matter
what the [__] it is i mean i'm not a big
i like the underworld movies they're not
classics to me i bet they're classic to
somebody else but
you know everybody's jumping on poor
[__] uh this poor kid now because
he's slinging dick let him sling dick
he's a great kid he's funny as [__] and
he's just listen i don't know if you've
ever been around a warm person
pete davidson
to top all his tattoos and staten island
and sat night live
he's a warm sweet [__] kid
i met pete davidson doing uh
doing uh opium anthony
i forget who was on with us but him and
i had a blast we were smoking a vapor
pen and [__] back and forth then i saw
him at the store one night and he was
buck wild again i gave him some [__]
uh joey diaz murder reefer he was all
happy and [__]
but kids
i'm a 58 year old [__] kid when you
get that through your head your life
will be a lot easier yes i'm serious and
i respect my business and i get up in
the morning and i work hard but i'm a
[__] kid
you know when you're a [__] kid you
just look and have fun
tomorrow is
thursday thanksgiving day is me and my
wife's anniversary
we've been together for 12 [__] years
when i met terry i was
i was 37 years old
if you thought
i was gonna marry terry
you got rocks in your [__] head
i wasn't gonna marry anybody
when i got into comedy i got divorced
and the whole thing
my goal was to do one thing and i swear
this to you guys
smoke pot
do coke
do comedy drive
and eat some [__] on the road
that's all i wanted to do
that was it
lenny bruce jr not that i have the
talent for lenny bruce
but i that's what comedy is you know
last year when all these people came out
with these [__] allegations against
this one and that one and myself they
forgot the most important thing about
comedy
people get into comedy don't get i mean
yeah you have some nice people in comedy
like bill burr and you know uh the guy i
like who's the funny guy i like that he
went to rehab and he dumped his wife and
he's little john mulaney
you know i
they're nice [__] guys you know like
that real sweet guys
well what the [__] was i talking about
oh yeah so when i met terry it was just
like
hang out until she figures out that i'm
a [__] loser and throws me the [__]
out that all i want to do is [__]
suck and eat and smoke dope
you know when is she gonna realize that
but terry
terry hit me different terry hit me from
a different spot guys you know like i
don't know if you've ever fallen in love
falling in love is [__] great and
i think one of my favorite [__] songs
when i'm in the radio like when i'm in
the car
the song that makes me the happiest is
remember the time when we fell in love
you know i know that's a song by michael
jackson
michael jackson writing it to his kids
and [__] you know whatever i think and i
mean me and mike are both from a heavy
metal world we both like [__] allison
chains nirvana we were talking about
pearl jam i think pearl jam is great i
was looking for an argument with mike
before i'm like [__] poke jam is the
best [__] batman there are 30 [__]
years they've been doing it no
complaints no drama you know they
bitched at tickatron when they were
young because they were confused they
wanted to be at top of the world but
they remembered what the [__] are we
we're not social whatever we're a
[__] band and they're [__]
phenomenal you know but anyway to get
back to terry like i didn't want to do
anything
but terry hit me for me we've all fallen
in love man and it's
you know what sucks about life for me
and mike right now
we'll never fall in love again
mike's with his wife i'm with my wife
those first couple of tingles
when you fell in love oh my god they're
[__] great and that's why i love that
michael jackson song i don't know if you
guys know the song i'm talking about
remember the time
that have you
have you seen that video lately
i mean i've watched it a million times
holy [__] when it's like watching david
lee ross i ain't got nobody
like it just takes your heart and just
david lee wrote i ain't got nobody's a
great [__] video
but eddie murphy's remember the time
with the model iman
eddie murphy
is a comedian
[Music]
the basketball player
magic johnson
magic johnson's in it with the hiv i
mean
but that song
is great because that's what it is
remember the time when you fell in love
oh my god calling them
[__] picking them up holding hands
and [__] going to get coffee having sex
the first couple times you really don't
[__] know what the other person likes
and [__] you know listen man it's great
and when i first started
dating terry
i hate to say this there was no love in
my heart like i didn't really have any
love i was a [__] dirty comic
i was looking to [__] people i'm sure i
had some diseases with me
i had like three or four diseases you
know i got fungi toenails not because i
got fungi toenails it's a mixture of
diseases that are in my body of [__]
viruses that are running through my body
i had a [__] positive
result a couple years ago for a syphilis
test
before mercy was born
now
i haven't been with nobody strains
in 20 [__] years how do you have
syphilis
in 2013 if you didn't have it in 2000
for years i was going to fit and then it
was a mistake you know i'm saying like
they came back with a mistake but i had
all that [__] i had chlamydia
i had all that [__] it just went away
eventually i didn't take anything for it
i think i put some [__] listerine on
my dick and took a ride jack you put
some listerine on your dick and wipe
your helmet
everything goes away plus when they suck
it they're like you dick tastes like
listerine it tastes minty it tastes
delicious but
when i first met terry there was no love
in my [__] future guys there was
i was a [__] caveman
you know it's like when i met joe rogan
he was still hunched over you know i
don't remember that podcast i said that
to him i go when i met joe rogan he was
still an ape he was still hunched over
doug and then little by little he
straightened up then he smoked pot and
[__] and it was on you know what i'm
saying but when i met joe rogan he was
late when i met terry i was a [__]
savage man
it was not good the savage that i was
and i had a
tape down my [__] i mean listen guys
i lived with her we moved in together
after six months maybe
and we were together the whole [__]
time
and i'm the type of guy i didn't want to
disrespect her
when i lived with her and [__] like that
so i was pretty [__] good i was
really good
all that sexual [__] all that that went
out the window the only thing i was
doing when i was a terry that was bad
was smart and coke you know that's that
was the only thing without when i first
met her
i didn't want to break her heart
i realized that she was so [__] sweet
that
what would i you know i've broken other
women's hearts and i'm not [__] proud
of it but i did it
unknowingly
you know if you
i'm a good guy and i have a lot of good
points but i have a lot of bad points
too and i know that going in
one of my bad points is i'm not a
romantic guy i'm never going to get
roses and throw them on the bed and walk
over them i'm never going to carry it to
that rose bush i'll hold your hand you
know i'll hold your hand
i'll be there for you when when you need
me if you're sick and all that [__] but
i'm not a big romantic guy like when i
see people [__] on tv and they're
making love they
my whole lovemaking session lasts 10
minutes after 10 minutes i'm [__]
hungry i don't have time for this [__]
rolling around and kissing you and all
this you know women want you to make
love to them and then hug them and rub
their back and talk to them listen let's
go we got [__] to do and people to see
law and all this starting in 10 minutes
you know what i'm saying i mean i've
never been a romantic guy but i do care
for people and i
i genuinely cared for her from the
[__] uh
third day i care for anybody who feeds
me
that's my secret when they
wrote that cliches line a man uh uh
the quickest way to a man's heart is
through his stomach
they were talking about uncle joey and
i'm sorry to [__]
you know drop this on you right now but
it's the truth i
i always
loved women who [__] fed me like
without me asking them
oh my god makes my dick hard
you know a girl that you have a crush on
and the next day she brings you chicken
cutlets to school
that girl was getting a [__] big
surprise from uncle joy i was gonna take
care of her because i've always admired
people when i met terry the thing that
made her different from any other woman
that i was with at the time was that
she cooked for me on the like the fourth
date
she had me over we were both broke
we both said it to each other that were
[__] broke and she made me some
chicken
and some [__] black bread beans
and some cornbread and
it just felt great it just tasted like
love
it's that's the weirdest thing to say
but it just tasted like love when i ate
i'm like i gotta get away from this
[__] because she's gonna put a spell on
me and [__] make me fall in love with
it and she did
she [__] did against my [__] will
you know and it wasn't
i know you guys uh well what was the
[__] dog it was
her insides
what she was about
you know i
i always looked at bruce lee when he
used to date when he was married to his
wife
and i was like why would a [__]
good-looking guy get married to an ugly
white woman like that well she's not
an ugly white woman she just wasn't as
attractive as i thought she would be for
[__] bruce lee
and
bruce lee married her because he
he loved what she was you know and i saw
a show on tv years later like you know i
don't know 10 years ago and they were
interviewing sterling silifant or
whatever his name is he's one of
i think he was one of the guys that
helped bruce lee put together into the
dragon or something
he was something to do with enter the
dragon
and he spoke about whenever bruce lost
it
the only person that could really
put him back together was his wife linda
you know and i know from my experiences
at first i was very listen i come from
the old school cut that
you never go to nobody with your
problems
you know
like as a man you don't go to a woman
with your [__] problems you talk to
other guys or you
figure them out or or you know
do whatever you need to do about to
settle this problem but you don't
[__]
bring it to a woman but let me tell you
something
i did
i went against all the laws i went
against anything any man would do
because i decided why have her around
if she's not going to be a part of my
dream
why have her around why have anybody
around
if they're not going to be a part of
your dream if they're going to be a part
of your dream you got to tell them your
strong points
and your [__] weak points you know so
i went to her
like in 2001 or something like that and
i [__]
told her where i was struggling and what
i wanted and guess what she made sure i
didn't have that struggle anymore
nobody helped me
book roles like my wife did if you look
at my mdb go look at my mdb from 2000
to 2004 just don't look at the tv shows
look at the movies also
you're gonna go what the [__] did you do
when i did that
uh
q a in mountain view for the [__]
soprano movie the guy the curator the
guy that put it all together said
something that i never [__] know i
don't what do you guys think i sit at
home and count [__]
he goes this next guy i'm gonna
introduce
has over 75 credits on imdb and i
remember looking at him
going this guy's [__] lying to people
but guess what i [__] came home that
night and i looked at my mdb and holy
[__]
my mdb has a lot on it and you could see
the [__] development like
co-stars you know i was doing one days
on movies small movies and then i just
[__] rammed it up i did a good job as
a comic in l.a i did a good job with my
career as a comedian i wasn't the best
comedian but i was consistent
i stuck to it and i was [__] crazy
but i tell you what i wasn't that bad of
an actor either i never saw myself as an
actor i saw myself as somebody doing
something just to feed my [__] wife
and myself and
keep my cocaine habit intact
but after i did it a couple times i kind
of liked acting and i got into it and i
[__] you know i'm not a meisner guy
i'm not gonna sit here and tell you oh
you know um
i'm a [__] meisner guy i study a cat
no i just i got a booklet and when i get
an audition i open that booklet and
i take the sides and i do what the
booklet tells me to do to the t i write
a background for the guy i [__]
write a story for the guy i i fill in
all the [__] blanks so when i
put the audition on paper everything is
covered there when i put the audition on
tape i'm sorry everything is covered
nobody goes to auditions no more you go
you put your [__] auditions on tape
so i do the same thing over and [__]
over again i don't deviate from that
plan or anything
if the book that i use is the vanachobix
workbook advantage is a great acting
teacher in la
before i started studying with her she
had a
halle berry and she had
she won two academy awards back to back
nobody does that [__]
so i had to go see what this lady had to
offer
and i took like a private with her one
time like we just went over an audition
cost me like a hundred dollars for a
half hour
hundred dollars for a half hour between
me and you guys you know me i tell you
everything i think ralphie paid for it i
think i had to borrow the money from
ralphie and ralphie paid for the because
ralphie
used to go to a different lady so
ralphie understood that sometimes you
got to pay
to [__] get the right you know like
just to get it right i mean listen louis
guzman had an acting coach for years on
set gandalfini had an acting coach on
set that he went over everything with
you know all the big stars when they're
committed i'm not talking about these
overnight [__] fly-by-night
[__] i'm talking about these
dudes that you look at denzel
uh the joker whatever his name is
[__] uh
there's a lot of guys that when they
work
they pay listen you're getting six seven
i don't know what denzel makes he's
gotta be making a hundred thousand a day
or whatever but when you're making that
kind of money
you pay somebody
you pay somebody and those guys they
want big money like i told you my lady
was a medium range of anatomic one well
not really she wasn't even a medium
range she won two [__] oscars
so she won like i think like two i think
now she wants 400.
for an hour of coaching
so if you get yourself a 20 page
audition you know you get yourself a big
[__] audition this is the things you
need to do to get that [__] role in
to be great but they all had [__]
acting coaches on the set i just you
know i always knew about getting
defenie's acting coach i was thinking of
calling the dude but she must want 10
000 an hour now so i don't act as much
as i do
it's not i'm 58 nobody's writing roles
for a fat old [__]
cuban looking [__] dude but
you know what at another time if i get
busy i would consider taking an acting
class and learning all over again
you know i don't know what technique to
use meisner whatever i just use the vana
chubby technique and whatever she
borrowed from people no a couple of
years ago two years ago a kid at jiu
jitsu
shane
great guy
[__] built like a [__] gave me a
book about acting and that's another
great book i forget the [__] name but
now i have it in my draw
he gave it to me and i didn't read it
like i said it was a good book like i
kind of lied and then his friend who's
my friend also said you know his
dad
was a big time acting [__] coach i
forget what his name now guys i'm sorry
so i looked the father up and i read
that book the next [__] day and that
book is great so now when i get an
audition i also look at that book also
but anyway
who gives a [__] about that the reason
why i booked
all those projects
was because i came clean with my wife my
girlfriend at the time she wasn't even
my [__] life
i came clean with something i never even
dreamed of doing i would never do before
and ever since i did that i opened up
the door
to what's called a real relationship
see we're living like fake relationships
the relationship i had with my first
wife and all the girlfriends that didn't
work out they were fake relationship
that's why it didn't work out
i was using
not using the word isn't using
the word is
when i had these relationships
i wasn't 100 committed
what do you mean by committed i wasn't
cheating i don't like cheating on people
because i don't like how you how i felt
when somebody cheated on me
so i don't like cheating on people so i
don't mean committed by being all in i
didn't cheat on any of them i haven't
cheated on anybody since [__] i was
in grade school grabbing school i
cheated on a girl and i didn't i didn't
make me feel right
the chick i cheated on her with
is now god knows where she is
and she broke up some kid ratted me out
to her and guess what they're still
together and they're still [__]
married but anyway who gives a [__]
about that my point is that i wasn't
committed
committed is when the other person knows
everything about you
i was too much on my high horse when i
had met the other women
and i wasn't mature enough to understand
these things that
when you're with somebody whether you're
a man or
or you're with a woman this advice is to
all you guys and trust me this is what
saved my ass
i did even with my first wife
she knew i went to prison she knew all
that [__]
but i was i was honest with her
but i wasn't all in with her what does
that mean that means that
i didn't share my struggles with her and
she didn't share
hers with me and when she tried to share
hers with me i would shut it down and
i'm really sorry for that
that's what
really puts together a relationship
is when you're both sharing your
struggles i'm not talking about mike i
need 10 bucks for the rent this month
we'll split the rent no anybody could do
that that's what couples do i'm talking
about
really sitting down
with your loved one and trust me
guys i had never done this before
don't think that i'm saying this to you
because
i didn't discover this till i was 37
years old 38 years old and i didn't
discover it it just happened
and then i saw the result of it and the
result is
that thursday we're going to have our
21k first anniversary
our 12th anniversary of being married
which means nothing compared to that
we've been together
21 years and if i have to credit
anything like if people came to me and
said
listen
people stay married for 50 years
80 years 40 years
and they give you advice and you listen
to it you know
i'm a [__] bum you know saying i'm a
[__] idiot
i'm really happy about 21 years because
i would never had gotten to this goal i
would have never gotten to this number
if i didn't do the things i was telling
you
i included her in my life
the struggles
listen i wasn't honest with her about
the coke at the time
but once i cleaned up from the coke
i sat her down
and i explained my whole struggle to her
when i came
to new jersey and
i was eating the xanax and it rebounded
and i got sick
i didn't hide it from her that's the
first person i went to she knew i was
eating the xanax the whole time i mean
she was she was there with me watching
me going joey be careful with those
things i'm only in a half i'm start i
didn't know what she was talking about
rebound anxiety if i were to listen to
her i wouldn't be in this position right
now so
when you're in a relationship i mean
i'm gonna have a great time with a
tomorrow and thursday uh today and
tonight my daughter gets her promotion
in uh
kickboxing at fat joe's she gets up
tonight to blue belt or blue belt too i
don't know what the [__] it is
so we're gonna go out to dinner to
celebrate the blue belt
and me and my wife being together 21
years but our real anniversary it's
thursday it's tomorrow for thanksgiving
and i didn't get her a gift yet so when
i finish up here i gotta run and get her
at least the [__] cards you know what
i'm saying i don't know what to get her
for her anniversary but i get like a
card and a piece of [__] she doesn't
like expensive jewelry so thank god i'm
off the hook there i could just get like
some [__] uh
charm for a bracelet or something like
that but
i love my wife
it's been a great
12 years of marriage you know
you heard me for years on the church and
on here i never wanted to get married
she made it
seem [__] easy
i mean the first time i got married
i hate that [__] the wedding and trying
on tuxedos and all that [__] i'd rather
stick a [__] pencil in my eye
but you know what man i give uh
i'm really happy that
i said [__] it i'm gonna marry this
woman
i got on one knee but i called the first
i proposed her on the phone i'm like
listen man we've been together for too
long
this has to come to an end and uh we're
gonna get married she's like really i'm
gonna hang up with you and call your
father i did that when she got home that
night i think i got on one day i'm not
sure i just told her i loved it i want
to marry her we put away some money our
wedding costs a thousand dollars
thousand dollars and we're still
together so for all you [__]
women that
want to get white birds and all this
[__] and then a year later find out that
he's [__] the ugly housekeeper like
right now like arnold schwarzenegger was
and [__] uh you know what was the
chick what's the chick from desperate
housewives a little cute mexican eva
langoria she had a wedding with pigeons
and [__] she married that cheating
brother [__]
that dude was [__] her sister
the [__] the black dude from the san
antonio spurs you guys remember
they had the wedding they kissed 18
times everybody banging glasses letting
pigeons loose and he was [__] the
housekeeper so who cares my wedding
costs a thousand bucks we got married at
a [__] third rate chapel and we had a
party at the hollywood [__] bowl we
got
chicken from
ralph's they have the best fried chicken
in that way there's no fried chicken
outlet but rob's is at least like a six
we got
pork chunks
from el cocinito the cuban place and i
got pastrami from the best pastrami in
california language
we line that [__] up we got some
reefer
and we told people not to bring gifts
and dress however the [__] you want we
got married on a [__] wednesday
and you're like joey why would you get
married on wednesday because i didn't
want to take people saturday away from
them so for all you [__] that
want to get married on the [__]
saturday and have us there all day go
[__] yourself there's college football
there's football there's [__] going on
and you want to drive this from there
when you pick a date make sure it's
after march madness and before baseball
season starts your [__] suckers
yeah
get married on a [__] wednesday don't
why are you gonna ruin people's weekends
and for you [__] that have those
vacation destinations wedding i hate you
[__] i hate you with all my heart who
the [__] do you think you are to make
people fly to another [__] country so
you get married
celebrate our joy [__] you in your
[__] joy all i'm looking at is a
three thousand dollar tab that you ain't
lifting the rock so you want me to
[__] pay to go to see your joy go
[__] yourself you get married in the vfw
the same place you started sucking [__]
when you were in high school after the
[__] dance and [__] what the [__] is
wrong with people i'm gonna fly to some
[__] vacation destination who the
[__] are you if your wife is sucking
dicks for everybody like a door prize
that would be great you know what i'm
saying what about a blow job if we go to
a
destination [__] wedding but just to
go to a destination wedding to lose
three thousand
three g's to see you [__] kid oh and
then they hit you with requests we're
doing a a a party you all have to dress
in white no it's not happening wait
listen come on come here didn't you have
chlamydia two years ago you suck some
guys at a disco and [__] and now you
want to have a [__] all-white knock
it off we're gonna give you a pass we're
wearing white at the wedding you know
you've had that whole busted since you
were 15. you know what i'm saying we're
gonna go along with your white dress
we're not gonna say nothing yeah
god and all that [__] but don't make me
go to your destination wedding i
practice what i preach [__] i
don't
i don't want to take any time from you
[__] at all it's even like the
podcast we used to do a podcast for
three hours [__] that who's got three
hours lex friedman keeps calling me
every week what are we doing the podcast
i'm in new york this week lex you got to
chop that down to [__] an hour i'm
not talking to nobody for three hours
i'm not in the [__] mood to talk to
anybody for [__] three hours you know
what i'm saying
what the [__] is wrong with people one
hour in out tip top magoo get the [__]
out of here just like i'm about to do
right now you bad [__]
i had like i said i had a guest today on
zoom we're gonna do a nice warm podcast
for thanksgiving but that didn't [__]
work out i was gonna show up with a
cornucopia of love for you [__]
today but steve's uh
zoom wasn't working today and i'm not
mad at him i don't care we'll get
stephen here some other time i had a
good time just telling you about my
[__] marriage my anniversary
and thanksgiving as you can tell i'm
really happy about thanksgiving you know
i never liked the [__] holidays
i don't want to sound like a [__]
whatever but i never liked the [__]
holidays and you're saying why joey
because i had pain connected to him i
don't have parents who enjoys christmas
with no [__] parents but guess what
i had a little beautiful girl nine years
ago eight years ago and
she makes christmas halloween and
[__] thanksgiving just
so much more [__] special you know
scenario i get nice and high for it not
high smoking weed i just get i get hyped
for the [__] holiday you know
what i'm saying i'm excited about that
turkey tomorrow and that stuffing my man
from el nido joe i want to thank him for
throwing me an organic 18 pound [__]
turkey we're gonna bring up
to my uh
to mercy's godfather's house tomorrow or
whatever tonight and they could cook it
tomorrow he's supposed to come down i'm
still waiting for the call
hey man it was a rough year for all of
us so i hope you all really take a
minute tomorrow and really
really be grateful for the people that
are at that table that are still there
be grateful for the year we've had we're
not dead
we're not dead a lot of people went into
the hospital and didn't come out guys
you know i whatever [__] you in the
vaccine [__] you in the no vaccine i
don't give a [__] i just want you to be
happy tomorrow on thanksgiving day
tomorrow is real special for us
seriously
so i'll check in with you [__]
tomorrow at some point of the day
wish you a happy uh thanksgiving and
whatnot but
i want you to think about the last 18
months and what
we've all gone through this country has
gone through
tomorrow's a special [__] day man
make it special
make it the best [__] day of the year
christmas is great because you're
giving gifts and [__] you know tomorrow
we're giving [__] thanks to the
universe for protecting us for saving us
for keeping us healthy during this
[__] horrible thing horrible things
have happened
the last [__] the 18 months look at
this last weekend that guy running over
those people had a christmas thing in
one ocean my heart goes out to those
families there were kids and old people
the dancing grandmas
i just want to wish you all
a happy thanksgiving with your families
look at them all in the face and tell
them how much you love them and that's
it [__]
the joint is in full [__] effect i
put a picture of the pipe freeze
on the on the internet yesterday freeze
pipe and people weren't [__] nuts
i've been smoking that thing let me tell
you how much i like to freeze pipe when
you don't smoke it
your throat hurts
like now that's the only bad negative
thing i have to say about the freeze
pipe when you don't smoke it
you can't quit smoking it's like once
you go on freeze pipe you ain't going
back it's like a black [__]
you ain't going back to some little
white three-inch [__] with with freckles
on it those days are over you're gonna
stick with that black [__] malukia
thick of death
and that's it and that's that listen
guys i love you at all my heart
thank you for supporting the joint thank
you for supporting my patreon thank you
for supporting laughing gas that reef is
getting stronger the ice cream shop i
love them with all my heart i'm working
hard to get my license here in jersey to
become a recreation [__] dispensary
but if not
i'll bump into all these abx
just we're gonna release a new [__]
200 milligram
abx capsule i don't know what they're
gonna call it yet the devil's tongue or
the devil's kisses or something like
that
so i'll keep you [__] posted in
the upcoming months
i love you guys happy thanksgiving god
bless your families uh
that's it
i love you i'll see you monday
tip top magoo [__] stay black
all right i want to thank all you guys
and wish you a happy thanksgiving thank
you for being with us today i want to
thank steve simone for at least shrine
we'll get it back and we'll get him on
the show but
from the heart of [__] new
jersey and uncle joey's nutsack the
joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen to me nba nfl nhl
those seasons are in full effect college
football college basketball's here
this is the [__] season to make some
guinness you don't have to go [__]
nuts with 100 25 wins you great money
they have great odds over a draftking
sportsbook listen to me
the nfhl season is underway and
draftking sportsbook has a tremendous
deal for you ready for this
the only way to warm your nuts is to win
a little [__] money will the philly
flyers win over tampa bay the world
champions who the [__] knows but listen
draftkings is here for you to place a
nice little bet with whatever you want
to do a little college football some
parlays they also have the same game
paul a's and like i said to you the
props out of this world monday night
football i didn't bet the [__] game i
bet for them to score you could also bet
on the field goal to score and they have
a tremendous social network so we could
catch up on there and talk some [__] it
doesn't matter if you're a one-time
clapper or a deaf
however you light the lamp they [__]
you win that's all that matters
and if sportsbook isn't available in
your in your state yet don't worry about
it draftkings won't leave you in the end
they got a tremendous daily fantasy
that goes on every day and they give
away huge cash [__] prizes
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot out of millions of dollars in
total prizes with their first deposit
this is the season to make money i don't
know what the [__] you're doing
scratching your head let's make a little
guitarist you don't got to bet over your
head and you're not going to have a
gaming problem i'll tell you why
because draftkings is covered whether
it's paypal money credit card money it's
it's it's they do a system that is
tremendous they're safe secure reliable
and best of all
they're trustworthy and you withdraw
your cash whenever you want take it from
uncle joey download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
joey throw down a dollar bet
on the nhl game and win
if a score hits the [__] if they just
score that's it if one puck goes in the
nets you win big with promo code joey
j-o-e-y
you got to be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pa only new customers only
minimum five hour deposit dollar wager
required
one per customer please restrictions
apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you've got
a gaming problem i want you to take care
of it call 1-800 gamble but if you don't
let's get this [__] party
started and head over to draftkings and
win some [__] getus the joint is also
brought to you by
manscaped listen to me i've been sitting
here with manscape for three years i
don't know about you guys my ball sack
looks great the area around my dick
looks great it smells great
and that's what [__] manscape has to
offer the trimmer is tremendous you
could cut you could trim cut the hairs
on your ball sack without even looking
at them they have a light it's
waterproof and the ceramic blades
reduces grooming accidents it's gentle
on the jewels and even gentler on the
[__] pogo stick and it's waterproof
you can shave your nuts in the shower
and now you can pair it out with the
manscape's new body wash it's aloe vera
and sea salt oh my god it leaves you
feeling nice and moist
you want to taste it your nutsack but we
don't do that here just in time for the
holidays they got the two in one
conditioner the whole package works
together from the top of your head to
the bottom of your [__] toes even
your little [__]
mushroom whatever your [__] little
fungi toenail that's why it's called the
perfect package and i'm gonna give you a
deal on it you order right now you're
also gonna get the weed whacker you're
gonna get
the [__] lawnmower 4.0 you're
going to get the crop preserver and the
crop revival which is a tremendous ball
toner and they got some anti-shaving
boxes for you
and a travel bag come on man listen
manscape is doing everything they can to
make your [__] man area look like a
[__] savage you understand me shave
those nuts perfume them keep them nice
and smooth that's what women like and
what they're going to do is they're
going to give you 20 off and free
worldwide shipping at manscape.com
bulgaria somalia you filthy animals
raise your hands and get some manscape
you don't have to walk around with your
dick looking like a savage you could
look like a [__] civilized man now
like i said manscaping giving you 20 off
and free worldwide shipping at
manscape.com
joey clean up your [__] candy cane
for the holidays with manscape i also
want to thank
cbd line for always having our back and
for being the best cbd on the market how
do i know because i've been working with
them for three years i went through two
surgeries with them and they've been
nothing but [__] tremendous with my
knee i use the kinesiology tape i still
before i go to the gym you could tell
the [__] samples are getting smaller
and smaller i cut a little piece of
kinesiology tape and i put them on both
shoulders so i don't have no problems
when i go to the gym go to cbdlion.com
right now they got bath balls they got
tincture they got the joints that you
could smoke the the sour space candy it
tastes great and you'll be nice and
calmed down after you finish it cbd lion
read go to their webpage and look at the
three
lab results read about cbd cbn and cby
and find out why cbd lion
is the best cbd on the market and i'm
telling you this and i got a lot of
problems and i got a lot of [__]
pains cbd line is for you use code joey
and get 20 off
and it gets delivered right to your
house you don't even have to leave the
house that's what cbd lion will do for
you i want to thank manscape i want to
thank cbd lion
i want to thank
[__] who else was on this week
draftkings who's always my main dogs
blue chew
on it and i want to thank me undies for
always taking care of us meundies
on it no me undies blue chew and
manscape everything focused around your
dick i love you [__] have a great
thanksgiving and i'll see you guys
monday
tip
top magoo stay black
[Music]
you